I can't believe it's the ninth season of
Curb Your Enthusiasm there's no went
away for a bit people are so happy that
that's coming back that looks like it
would be a fun experience it's it's the
it's the dream you know it's like I have
to I have to go to work tomorrow should
I prepare no you don't have any lines so
you just show up I
I know and love they you know Larry
Daley I called him David that's how well
I know and love him did you see me Ellen
show the other day I said she said so
what's it like being 69 I said well
Helen and that's what it's like they
shoot on this lot I see her all the time
I'm always calling her Helen Beatrice
you know yeah I know it just gets under
her skin so I do it and then she calls
me Conrad but you know it's interesting
because I you know it's a show where you
get to improvise and it looks like you
guys yes you have lines but you also
just get to screw around a lot on that
show yeah I mean it's worked out so you
know you know the direction you're
supposed to go and then like all
improvisation half of its crap so you
you you know don't do that do this if we
go in that direction it's not good say
that that was funny so by about the
sixth time you've done it you really
improvised this script yeah but it's fun
your job is to basically push Larry into
a corner until he gets so pissed off he
explodes yes and then he's more Larry I
don't know that everybody loves ya that
just bait him it's like he's a pole in
you're just right on him watch this
you